[Musique]
voici le film de l'attentat qui a coûté
la vie au président Kennedy avec sa
femme Jacqueline il était arrivé à
Dallas au cours d'une tournée politique
dans le sud des États-Unis et descendait
dans une voiture découverte la grande
rue de la ville pour gamier le bâtiment
où il devait prononcer un discours
devant le conseil local des
citoyens soudain des coups de feu
c'était
[Musique]
l'attentat le tir était parti du 5e
étage d'une grande bâtisse où les
policiers découvrirent aussitôt une
carabine à lunett arme d'une précision
redoutable puisque le président avait
été tué d'une seule balle dans la tête
bientôt aprs on arrêta un
suspectoswald qui tira sur les policiers
venus l'arrêter tuant
l'un dans les rues l'émotion était à son
comble l'annonce de la mort du jeune
président touchait au plus profond l'âme
populaire et cette émotion devait en un
minimum de temps s'étendre au monde
entier au Nations Unies le président
levait la séance en signe de deuil et
dans toutes les capitales les
gouvernements décrét un deuil
officiel
[Musique]
le président était mort sur la table
d'opération 25 minutes après l'attentat
son corps devait le soir même être
transféré à Washington où accompagné de
Jacqueline Kennedy il était conduit à la
Maison Blanche avec les honneurs
[Musique]
fun
de partout parvenaient les témoignages
d'un deil universel et le général de
Gaulle décidait de se rendre à
Washington pour y assister au funérail
du président assassiné il s'y retrouver
avec les chefs d'État et les chefs de
gouvernement de quelques
[Musique]
nations à la Maison Blanche les
personnalités rendaient hommage à la
dépouille de John Keny
et courageux qui être ferme à des heures
difficiles et qui laissera le souvenir
d'un grand homme
[Musique]
d'État à Paris éisabeth bon une jeune
artiste en tapisserie a vu sa vocation
encouragé par un chèque de 10000 francs
avec elle devant un aréopage de
célébrité 23 jeunes qui ont manifesté
leur volonté de suivre la voix qui les
appelait ont reçu ce même
encouragement
en offrant une nouvelle fois à des
jeunes gens et des jeunes filles le
moyen de réaliser une ambition que
peut-être ils n'auraient pu réaliser
faute d'argent la fondation de la
vocation créée et animée par Monsieur
blestin Blanchet continue d'assumer sa
belle
[Musique]
tâche ance dans le palais des congrès
dont les abord transformé en galerie
d'exposition présentai les dernières
réalisations françaises s'est déroulé la
journée de la 5
mieur Michel debr et monondon messieur j
perfit 23 ministres réunis sous la
présidence d'André mer avec 3000
délégués venus de toutes les régions de
France ont écouté le discours du premier
ministre monsieur George Pompidou qui
adressé le bilan de l'action
gouvernementale depuis 5 ans et indiqu
le sens des efforts qui seront fait dans
l'avenir nous travaillons a-til dit et
nous continuerons de travailler pour les
20 prochaines
années
chancelier depuis un mois qui est ludv
un homme qui aime toujours lire des
livres d'économie dans l'intimité de son
bureau où des photographies évoqu le
canonnier de 1914 et le fils du Mercier
qu'il fut un ber un homme aussi qui dans
cette maison du lac de toger aime à
jouer les grands-pères des
[Musique]
bonniss loin des débats parlementaires
il s'est réservé un cadre familial où il
aime retrouver une épouse une fille des
petits-
enfants l'homme public on avait commencé
à le mieux connaître en septembre 1949
quand le gouvernement adenoer dans
lequel il était ministre de l'Économie
prenait officiellement en charge le
destin de l'Allemagne de l'Ouest mais
ludvich cherart avait déjà influé sur le
destin d'un pays ruiné par la guerre où
tout manquait les moyens de
communication comme la nourriture et sur
lequel le régime des restrictions pesait
quotidiennement de tout son
poids conseiller économique des
autorités alliées il avait mis au point
la réforme monétaire de juin 1948 qui en
changeant la monnaie renversa la
situation économique il pu voir se
réaliser ce qu'on a appelé le miracle
économique
[Musique]
allemand en moins de 10 ans ce fut le
retour de l'abondance la prospérité de
l'Allemagne é allée aux yeux du
monde depuis il a gardé le goût assez
singulier des visites dans les
marchés lors de sa nomination au poste
de chancelier la jeunesse allemande est
venue le saluer comme le symbole
rassurant de cette prospérité que les
Allemands lui
[Applaudissements]
doient tel est l'homme qui a succédé à
celui qu'on appela aussi le chancelier
de fer et qui vient d'être reçu à Paris
au Palais de l'Élysée le chancelier
herart devait rencontrer pour la
première fois en tant que chef de
gouvernement le Général de Gaulle
rencontre qui a permis aux deux hommes
d'État d'évoquer les problèmes auxquels
sont confrontés la France et l'Allemagne
et sur lesqueles ont porté à l'Hôtel
Matignon les conversation avec le
Premier ministre monsieur George
Pompidou autant Europe marché
[Musique]
commun
au Capitol devant le cercueil de bronze
qui renferme le corps du président
assassiné la première à s'agenouiller ce
sera Jacqueline Kennedy et sa fille de 6
ans Caroline et les mots manquent devant
cette scène d'une émotion
[Musique]
poignante dehors une immense qui pendant
des heures défilera devant le cercueil
apportant un dernier hommage au
président
[Musique]
disparu mais presque à la même heure à
Dallas un nouveau drame imprévisible lui
aussi s'est
[Musique]
déroulé encadré de policiers l'assassin
présumé loswald était à son tour victime
d'un meurtrier devant les caméras et les
journalistes blessé au ventre par un
certain Jack Ruby lioswald devait
succomber sur la table d'opération
nouveau mystère qui s'ajoute au mystère
de l'attentat
présidentiel l'heure des funéraille
sonnet à Washington
entre ces deux beaux frères le ministre
de la Justice Robert et le sénateur
Edward Jacqueline Kennedy suivra le
convoi funèbre devant les chefs d'État
et les chefs de gouvernement de plus de
50 nations jusqu'à la la cathédrale
[Musique]
saint-mthieu accompagné de safille
Caroline et du petit John Fitgerald dont
le 3e anniversaire tombe justement ce
jour-là au son de ce même av Maria qui
accompagna la cérémonie de son mariage
Jacqueline Kennedy va prendre sa place
devant le président Lindon Johnson et
les délégations où l' connait la reine
de Grèce le roi des Belges le général de
Gaulle le président lupque et le
chancelier herart y représent
[Musique]
l'Allemagne monsieur krutchov a délégué
son second monsieur
[Musique]
Mikoyan à cette même heure dans le monde
entier tous les hommes de bonne volonté
ont eu une pensée pour cet homme épris
de justice et d'humanité qui porta à
certaines minutes le destin du
monde avec ses deux enfants Jacqueline
Kennedy va maintenant assister au départ
du cortège vers le cimetière
d'Arlington et c'est l'inoubliable geste
d'un petit garçon orphelin d'hier et qui
salue
[Musique]
au milieu des 126000 tombes où dorment
les grands mort des guerres d'hier John
fitgérald Kennedy reposera mort aussi
dans l'accomplissement de son devoir
mort au combat victime peut-être de
l'action qu'il menait et du sens qu'il
donnait à sa
[Musique]
mission mort comme un soldat sous le feu
comme l'a dit le général de Gaulle pour
son devoir et au service de son pays
laissant un grand
[Musique]
exemple et la flamme allumée par
Jacqueline Kennedy et qui brûlera
désormais sur la tombe du président
assassiné sera le signe que son exemple
restera dans le souvenir comme il
restera dans
[Musique]
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]